Eccolo Guarda
Eccolo questo è prima edizione cioè
Favij tu sei in possesso di una carta
veramente molto rara si potrebbe
aggirare sui 2000 euro
Avete presente quando vi svegliate la
mattina e scoprite di avere 2000 euro
Io sì grazie Federic questa cosa non la
sapevo come potete vedere ragazzi Questo
è il Charizard in questione Ma voi non
lo sapete
[Musica]
sono due che se la matematica non è
un'opinione Uno vale 2000 due valgono ma
tra l'altro
questo video sarà senza Giampiero Oggi
ho deciso di andare da Federic per
appunto mostrargli il mio Charizard non
ci fanno affidare soldi per lavorare Non
lo so infatti
Porca [ __ ] Scusate la cosa
particolare di essere arrivati da
Federic e che non si capisce dove sia
perché siamo in una via desolatissima
quindi è proprio Federico stesse con
Pokémon raro troveremo Federic e
speriamo a chiamarlo No no Non si fa
così non hai visto che uno che chiama un
Pokémon Immagino che questo sì questa
sia la forza e poi come incontrare il
professor Rock invece non mi chiede se
sono un ragazzo e una ragazza subito mi
Ma buonasera
abbiamo scommesso che mi avresti chiesto
se sono un ragazzo a una ragazza prima
cosa però Vabbè fa niente ti faccio
vedere io che professori cosa stai
dicendo No ma qua è una macchina del
tempo io avevo un Pikachu che
rivoltandolo diventava Pokémon cioè e
sarebbe questo qui una roba del genere
così e dentro c'hai la la Poké Ball
molto simile molto simile guarda e pensa
che gliela regalato il ministro degli
Esteri giapponese a quello cileno quando
andavo ti immagini il ministro degli
Esteri giapponese che viene quello raga
eh raga Di Maio Uh una Poké Ball che si
di volta bellissimo giustamente dice che
metà verso quelli in cui viviamo
Quindi visto io vado un attimo in bagno
bene Ragazzi abbiamo colonizzato
l'ufficio di Federic come se fossimo il
Team Rocket Innanzitutto mi sta piacendo
prima eh Spiegami Per quanto riguarda
questi ah
minuti e io ok questo primo mazzo dove
all'interno c'era il famosissimo Machamp
prima edizione perché questa carta può
essere trovata solo qua dentro essendo
chiuso ovviamente il suo valore aumenta
tantissimo questi sono tesori che io il
mio staff Cerchiamo in giro per tutta
Italia poi ci sono tutti i Charizard più
incredibili pazzi
Mamma mia quando qualcosa funziona e
questa è il famoso charizardry Esatto Ci
tengo a precisare che quando andavo alle
scuole elementari io possedevo
esattamente questo Charizard qui ma eh
Che valore hai invece hai esagerato
Questo questo gradato si parla di anche
30-40 mila euro di carta
[Musica]
Sì ho fatto un conto Insomma diciamo che
se sommi tutto tutto siamo sui sei Zeri
più o meno però devi contare veramente
tutto quello che ho fatto
anche proprio nella in banca
io mi immagino chi non si intende che ti
riporti Vabbè cosa gli porti oro
diamanti no Eh guarda c'ho un Charizard
Va bene allora parlerei dell'unico avere
Pokémon esco Pokémon esco che ho io
possiamo io quando ho fatto la Reaction
Cioè quel video adesso mi dice che non
vale più niente eh mi ammazzo mai anzi
dal video che ho fatto poi per ora non
metto tanto ancora di più Vabbè ma
guarda che è un anno eh
mi piace fare video Questo ragazzo è un
grande un sacco di tempo è passato nel
tempo e quindi the Pokémon Quanto vale
ce l'hai qua Subito chiamo delicatissima
[Musica]
non so che cosa hai detto ma mi è
piaciuto
ragazzi però comunque è bellissima carta
adesso il valore perché non mi valuti
quest'altra carta Ah ce ne hai due o
meno chi non me lo ricordavo potrebbe
essere un 10 pieno perché smussato e
messe dentro Diciamo che questa carta
firmata dall'artista Quindi questa cosa
Rita può valere anche più di €2000
Comunque c'hai un bel Tesoretto se vuoi
queste le possiamo mandare a gradare le
manderemo siamo nello studio di Federic
dove Eh praticamente oggi ti abbiamo
invaso casa e lo su il bagno Quindi
niente questo non avrai più niente di
tutto questo perché Giampy si sentono le
cose non lo so oh oh oh qua c'è il Santo
Graal strano perché oggi ancora non
abbiamo visto gli ufficiali sappiamo
Quindi questo è il primo è il cha
Charles Poi vedi non ha l'ombra bruciata
e infatti questo Guarda adesso ti faccio
fare una cosa Vieni qua Vai grazie Non
so che tutti Regal tutte le cose agli
ospiti ma non dovevi cioè questa cosa
proprio andata troppo troppo troppo
Grazie grazie mille Pensa che io volevo
prendere questi questi sono nel mio
battesimo è vero ma me li tolgo la cosa
strana li posso togliere Ormai c'ho la
testa più grossa perché ce l'ho da
quando non è un neonato niente È
bellissimo grazie Quando fanno il
battesimo i bambini non regaliamo più
questa Cosa regaliamo i Charizard Shadow
dipende
qualsiasi valore abbia lo di
moltiplicare perché è bellissimo Qua
abbiamo i fantastici box ovviamente
vetrina inespugnabile che voglio dire
questa chiave senza questa chiave non la
apre neanche Godzilla impossibile stanno
circa sui 70 mila euro l'uno i box più o
meno amico mio grazie È stato fantastico
Ciao bello è stato super Mamma mia
ragazzi è stata un'esperienza pazzesca
poi lui si è simpatico un bravissimo
ragazzo
comunque Eh insomma le carte quelle
buone
le portiamo a casa eh
È bravissimo ragazzo bene arrivederci